i don't want to go live anymore what do
i do
no no go live go live
just a second ah starting aha
receiving your content your audience
will see it in a moment
this appears to be working yes we are
live
it just says pi data yeah yeah so the
youtube link doesn't work
ah i don't want to go live anymore no
now the youtube link works we're live we
[Music]
okay you cannot one cannot have you you
need to like
um mute the youtube part i did it i did
it it's gone it's there's no feedback
okay that was very entertaining if
everything is fine i'm going to leave if
at some point something goes wrong i'm
home
so just write me okay thank you thank
you noah so much this is
been a great help um alone can you share
your screen again so i can check what's
happening in the uk um
okay i'm gonna run upstairs and get my
phone so that we can i can i'm going to
tweet the link to the live stream on
youtube
[Music]
uh what do you see you know well okay
the livestream
has everything but dislikes dislikes to
be honest
[Music]
okay wow um interesting
i don't know how to pick ah yes now it
has the slides
okay i wonder how i can search
how i can see what's like
well in theory you can open the live
stream
and in another
and on the youtube have feedback of what
you're sharing
yeah but it will have delay um
but on zoom you don't see
um so just to be clear right now you can
only see the slides you can't see the
zoom window right
no i see so give me
right now i have the zoom window
overlaid on the slide so can you read
the slides clearly or not oh yeah yeah
we only see the slides yes
we only see the slide
all right
cool cool cool cool nice
um okay so i'm gonna start admitting
people to the meetup
um
i hope they all behave well okay just to
clarify you go first right
yes i have a hard stop i will need to
drop it around
6 14 the latest my times of 740 autumn
okay yeah i'm gonna kind of kind of
power through the slides and uh if
anybody has any questions i'm
you know happy to take them by like
offline um
alone can you um share your screen still
because otherwise it's just
the youtube stream is all of our faces
which is
god entertaining yet awkward
so how much time for each presentation
um as much as you want 20 30 minutes
it's i mean i said that it's uh
about 30 minutes
i hope that's okay and how does it work
with the questions
um basically however you want it to work
so we can if you would like people to
ask questions by asking the question we
can do it otherwise we can have
people on the right asking questions on
the chat
um and then either
yeah so what we had before is we asked
participant to
ask questions on the chat um
and then at the end and then you can if
you want
i the misha and i or i can interrupt you
um and ask the question or if you would
like to have the questions at the end
it's up to you yeah i mean
um i'm happy to be interrupted
um yeah
maybe it would be best if uh we
introduced this
hand raised mechanism which i tend to do
during
like seminars um all the participants
they have this option of
raising their hand and this might be
the best approach without you being too
interrupted and
us basically seeing that somebody wants
to
to have a say what does it look like
can you raise your hand so we see how it
looks like
yeah sure hold on
um wait a minute where's my hand race
okay um there isn't this option
why isn't there this um i thought it
worked reasonably well
last time that the the questions
are just moderated through the chat
so people write their questions in the
chat and
and the moderator in this case noah or
uh misha you then ask
at the end of the talk the speaker those
questions
um this might work reasonably well also
because we now have the live stream
so if anyone is looking at that we're
gonna need to get some questions from
the live stream
also to um
to the to the speaker
how will people on the livestream ask
questions
there's a there's a chat on there
there's a chat on the
live youtube thing
um in theory i could basically keep
track of the
youtube chat and you could and know what
you could
keep track of or everyone else could
keep track of the zoom
group chat and unless the youtube chat
will be too crowded
i think i could handle it myself
okay yeah um
so and noah should we do it like this
that you basically open it up you
introduce
adam and then after that is done i will
basically emcee ellen
okay um and
okay
[Music]
with regards to questions again because
of the time constraint i'm
happier to leave it to the end if
there's time
yeah so alarm you would like to have
questions at the end
uh yeah okay i just want to make sure
that they get to the slides
before i have to draw but i yeah i'll
tell the
the participants to post their question
either on the youtube
um thing or on the zoom chat and
if we have time at the end then you'll
take the question yeah for sure and
happy to take
your questions offline
[Music]
um should we maybe also mute everyone
or how do we how do we want to do this
uh yeah we should move you to everyone
i can do it ah yes
um michael i'm gonna try to help you
with the uh with the youtube
comment page yeah thanks
so
ah okay also i would like to announce a
competition
that the person who is farthest away
from berlin
at the moment um gets stickers we will
send
them via post stickers so
we had this we had the same thing last
time
am i sorry yeah uh furthest away how
geographical distance or ping time
geographical distance i thought ping
time was a pretty good proxy
much more suitable for uh
for pi data
okay am i currently in the lead or is it
someone farther away
[Music]
from london last time we had yeah i'm
pretty sure there's someone further away
than london yes hello i'm from argentina
there we go
we might we might have a we might have a
problem with like
someone from argentina and then some
room from an equal
roughly equal distance away in some
other country in a completely opposite
direction
well i guess in that case we can't we
can send both of them some stickers
okay
we can also have a competition for the
person with the most awkward
time of the day okay vietnam we have
vietnam and tunisia
india oh i'm gonna need to get some is
this noah are we talking straight line
distance
we talk a great circle metric i would
say
euclidean metric right oh man is there
something is there some calculator thing
i can use for that
wow chile is getting google maps
google maps
[Music]
[Music]
okay i found distance calculator.net
okay distance calculator.net
fill into let's say buenos
aires
is eleven thousand nine hundred and ten
kilometers
actually for more precise uh position i
am from santa fe argentina
i'm sorry let's see if it brings you
closer or further away
santa fe i'm afraid there will be a
million santa
it gave me santa fe us i am very sorry
it's kind of ann
yeah hanoi hanoi is eight thousand three
hundred kilometers
no buenos aires wednesday is further
away
yes santa fe i'm sorry it's closer than
argentina than
buenos aires but you're still in iran i
think it's it's i think it's far from
um i think yes santa fe
argentina is eleven thousand seven
hundred and seventy nine
point nineteen kilometers but yeah so
who was from chile that should be
further away
yeah there was the person um
kazakhstan creed india china kenya
oh we should change the rules of the
game to calculate the distance between
where you are right now
and where uh home is no
yes but we
and we send one one one sticker to you
and one sticker to your parents
yes my parents really do uh need a few
more pie data stickers for their laptops
um okay i think we will
officially start and we will also
officially announce the game
um the contest and so hello
everyone and wait welcome to the pie
data virtual
meetup um i hope everyone
is healthy and happy and enjoying their
virtual life
and we were just discussing that it
seems that
having virtual meetups really allows us
to interact with people who are also not
based in berlin
and in this spirit we announce the
competition
um the person who is farthest away from
berlin
in kilometers is gonna get some pi data
stickers
so if you think you may be in the run so
far we have some people from
argentina and chile so please
send us either in the zoom chat or the
youtube
chat um the city where you're based and
if you are the farthest away
um we will ask you probably to send us
an email with your exact address um
because otherwise we can't really send
you anything
well otherwise we'll just send you uh
virtual stickers
yes so if you want to really say thicker
you will need to email us our
your exact address um
to our pi data at berlin.info we will
also write it in the comment section of
the meetup page
um other than that one more sorry
noah that the email address is info at
pi data dot berlin
yes i'm sorry to the email info at pi
data dot berlin um
yes and we will write it of course also
in the meetup section
in the comments of the meetup page um
one said announcement that maybe some of
you already heard
the the amazing conference uh python day
and pi data the
berlin 2020 has been unfortunately
cancelled
as we understood we won't be able we
won't be able to have it
um in the form and shape we wanted it
to be this year um mute we are we will
we are working very hard on having a
2021 conference
and we will release the dates um once we
have them
and we also would like to remind you
that our code of conduct
still applies also online please be kind
to each other
um and you can freshen up on the code of
product
on the nam focus website um and if
you're
watching via zoom please feel encouraged
and free to turn on your video
so alone can see us and know who he's
talking to
if you would like to ask questions
please write them on the
either the zoom chat or the youtube chat
and alarm is a bit limited with time
so if he has time after his presentation
he
um he will answer some of the questions
and if he doesn't get it he said you can
contact him
on twitter or github and you can take
the questions offline
um so without further
um notifications let's start with alan's
talk about getting an edge with network
analysis
in python thanks now can everyone hear
me all right
great uh well thanks for the intro uh
noi and i have been
talking about having this uh talk for
about six months or so i was
looking forward to doing it in berlin
but unfortunately that's not gonna
happen
uh so i'm doing it from a very hot uh
bedroom in london
um and today i'll give really a brief
introduction to network analysis
in python and uh
yeah as i mentioned i'm a little
constrained uh in time so
anything that i don't get to then then
please feel free to ping me on twitter
linkedin
email and so on i'm happy to take
questions offline if we don't have time
so uh let's just jump into it a little
bit
about me i'm a senior data scientist and
a data science leader
delivery which until recently was
available in goalie
and other than that i've mentioned i'm
london-based originally from tel aviv
uh on a personal note i haven't had a
hellcat in four months
due to corona and sometimes i tweet
interesting uh things on twitter so
feel free to follow me at all new um
so today as i mentioned a quick
introduction to network analysis
uh we are constraining time network
analysis is a huge
topic and you can find on youtube uh
uh workshops from pycons and pi data
conferences we
withdraw like three or four hours uh at
length just to introduce people to
network analysis and obviously we have
25 minutes or so so we are really going
to touch the bare bones on network
analysis so
my agenda for today my objectives are
very very simple
i want to show you uh that network
network analysis is extremely useful
and i also want to show you that it's
really easy to get started
um yeah so our plan is simple we'll
discuss
uh why should you should learn about
network analysis and a few motivating
examples
we'll give the very brief bail bonds
into
uh theoretical intro we'll analyze
real data with python so you can see
that it's
very easy to get started and time
permitting will explore more
useful and interesting examples from
real life
what we won't do in the interest of time
is to
yeah dive deep into the theory and
everything that
there is to learn because there is a lot
to learn and it's really fascinating
again for simplicity there will be no
math no metrics representation and no
greek letters whatsoever
uh we won't dive deep
into the theory behind the different
things that we'll see i think what's
important to know about
network analysis or what's cool about it
is that
sometimes the results we get are
intuitive
for a human for the human brain but they
are
very complex uh if you want to devise an
algorithm to do it
in an efficient way and finally and most
importantly
we are not going to use the seawall
today
it's tempting when you have a network
analysis talk to discuss about you know
how viruses spread and everything like
that but i feel like the world has had
enough of that in the last two or three
months
and i think the last thing you want to
do uh is to to hear about it some more
from me so we will not use that
more today um
yeah so next
quick kind of like intro as to why
and uh what you can do with network
analysis
um first of all i think that as data
scientists we come from
various backgrounds myself i come from
economics i have people in my team that
are
structural engineers and chemists and
biologists and
a few physicists and a physicist that's
you know that his speciality is in
lasers which is extremely cool but you
know
doesn't have anything to do with data
science and
network analysis is just one of those
things that it's extremely useful but
people don't really learn about it when
they transition into the desire so i
think it's something that
that's kind of a secret weapon but it
shouldn't really be a
secret weapon uh furthermore i think
that
humans as humans we tend to think
linearly or in like tabular form
but then if you add network analysis
onto that like all the network
representation of data
then you get like you kind of unlock a
new dimension
where you can really learn a lot more
from the data sets that you have
and finally it's just cool um
so let's let's let's be concrete here
let's talk about
actual problems that you may uh use to
use network analysis to solve and these
are actual problems and you can get paid
uh to answer these problems and i know
that because i was paid to answer these
problems with network analysis
um so let's assume that your product
data scientists for
peer-to-peer payments app i'm not sure
if there's something like that in berlin
uh in the u.s there's a a big service
called venmo
uh owned by paypal basically you know
i can i can then move you some money you
can vent my
uh it back um
in in the uk we have monzo which is
again the same
the same basic idea think about like
whatsapp only instead of sending
messages you send
you send uh you send some money um
and then you are the scientist and then
a few people around the business ask you
several questions the customer service
team could ask you
who's we we have a bunch of customers
calling us or sending a support request
who's and whose call should we answer
first who should we get
give white glove treatment to and who
can we de-prioritize in the list which
is a very concrete and good question
the marketing team could tell you hey
we've got some money for you know for an
influencers campaign
can you tell me who the influences are
so we could spend
that uh uh budget efficiently
the product team could ask you hey who's
our
well power users who do we want to kind
of keep in mind when we design a new
feature for example
and um the customer research team again
should
ask you questions like hey who do we
want to interview in the next time we do
any customer testing so actual real
questions
and of course there are many other use
cases in real life
everything pretty much everything could
be models and networks so of course
in real life uh there's a lot of
research and a lot of info about how you
can use your net
like funding a job is actually a network
analysis problem finding a spouse
anything on google really is just one
giant
network of data um how you
you know you can use network analysis to
detect bot or troll networks on twitter
you can detect people on reddit that
kind of
cheating with karma with the upvote
system um
if there's a financial crisis like in
the 2008 financial crisis
uh the obama administration to the best
of my knowledge used network analysis to
decide which banks to bail out and which
banks not to
uh you have personal personalized
recommendations which is which is a huge
use case for
network analysis it's pretty kind of
pretty intuitive
um you know if if you
like a certain movie for example and a
certain film
and then many people like
you know who like that film also like
these other films and we can recommend
you know another film for you and pretty
accurately and most importantly this is
an example i always
go back to voting in the eurovision can
be modeled
with network analysis and it has been
modeled with network analysis and given
the time we'll actually see it
live uh in action in a very very
interesting website
so what is it um you can go to wikipedia
and read this
incredibly interesting description which
is not very user friendly
uh in one common very very common sense
of the term a graph is an ordered pair
v and e comprising a set and so on and
so forth that's not very user friendly
and guess what it's even less
user-friendly when it's in german
because i don't
picture
so if we want to keep it simple we can
think of networks as just
points and lines if you can draw a
conceptual relationship between
any two things it's likely that you can
model them in the network
so just a few examples you know people
obviously
uh are an example of a network because
we have friendships we follow each other
and so on communicate with one another
companies trade with one another uh you
can think even of
like bus stops as as networks points on
a network and then buses that go from
one
stop to another uh from that network
similarly
a bicycle sharing screen countries
uh as we mentioned they exchange
eurovision points
and even wikipedia articles um pretty
much
any time i open wikipedia i find myself
kind of opening wikipedia just to read
this one article but then i find myself
clicking on a bunch of links and
opening more and more tabs to read other
things so
different um different articles on
wikipedia
could be models network and then they
are connected from one article to
another so that's essentially a network
which is pretty cool and there are all
sorts of like interesting exercises on
wikipedia
about you know uh like if you if you're
looking for a homework assignment from
this
from this lecture is like trying to
figure out you know how many steps does
it take to get from
point a to point b on wikipedia from an
article about
abraham lincoln to an article about tick
tock
right so the obvious example that we'll
use
today just intro ourselves to the
concepts of our network is facebook
which is something that we all know and
use so we have this blondie guy and he
there's another blonde person and they
are connected
on facebook great so those are the
points and lines
and then obviously if every every one of
them knows more people
and there are more relationships between
those people
and that's a very very simple basic
network that we just create
that's so far it's pretty
straightforward i think um
so apparently as it turns out those
points and lines
actually have real names uh in computer
science
the points are called nodes and the
lines are called edges or links
in math it's vertices and edges or arcs
in physics it's sites and bonds and in
sociology it's actors
which is cool and ties of relations and
a lot of the work around
network analysis actually comes from
social network analysis
there's a very famous uh paper by
malcolm
malcolm
which uh about yes
exactly about uh the the
the strength of weak ties it's been
cited more than 56 000 times so it's a
pretty popular day
we'll be using nodes and edges because
that's just
what i'm used to um very very high level
the main types of networks are directed
and undirected
undirected are like friendships on
facebook so if i'm not his friend on
facebook noah is also my friend
that's undirected and then there's
things like twitter for example or
snapchat or instagram
or tic tac where you know if i follow
noah's tik talks
it doesn't necessarily mean that norfolk
is mine um
and so on there are other things like
multigraphs and multi-direction graphs
but in the interest of time and
confusion we won't get it
um so facebook if you go back to our
facebook example
uh facebook is an undirected graph
and again applying our new terminologies
and
these are the nodes in blue and these
are the edges
in teal um and this point i'd like to
add just one more
concept into the mix and we'll see that
with these three things
uh nodes edges and paths which is the
next thing that i'm going to introduce
we can do some pretty cool stuff this
network analysis so paths
are just a collection of edges from one
point to another point from
one node to another another node on the
graph
as long as there's no repetition so any
any route any walk
from one node to another as long as
there's no repetition in
edges or notes that's a path so this is
one path in purple
this is a different path and yet another
one
so quick recap notes edges pass so far i
think so good right
cool i hope that's not cool no no okay
um so this is pi data so let's do it in
python
network x an amazing library um
that is very comprehensive it's it has a
very friendly uh api and documentation
um and it's like if you need to get
started network analysis do it with
network x because this is the most
robust and
friendly library there is out there uh
it doesn't
scale immensely great for like very very
big
graphs you can do it um you know with
other tools
uh and the visualization for large
graphs isn't really good either
uh and there are other tools you can use
like snappy graphic graph and gaffy
which is not
actually python but
so the data set we'll explore today
comes from venmo which is the service i
mentioned
earlier i'm gonna try to open a link
live in real time and hopefully it will
actually work
okay this is venmo okay as i mentioned
venmo allows you
one person to send another person uh
money on an app and the interesting
thing about venmo
is that those transactions are actually
public
so you can you know you can pick an api
or if you
for instance look for long enough in
dark corners of the internet you will
find you're likely going to find a large
data set that you could analyze
um so i'm gonna work some magic and i'm
gonna
try to do a bunch of stuff at the same
time
let's try to hmm there you go
one stack
let's stop the script here real quick
so you could see that in real time
things happen
okay apparently
yeah it's not gonna happen there you go
uh right so in real time this is
actually when venmo's website right now
and i just stopped the script from
update from updating it but you can see
transactions you can see connections
that have happened on them
so you can see a person named sky f paid
john g
a certain amount of money for virtual
coffee date which is great you can see
that julia has paid pluto as to help
with your bills this month and so on
these are actual transactions that just
happen on vendo
and what we can do we can analyze that
so for let's hop back for the
deck to the deck for just a second um
and actually let's go
to the jupiter notebook
i'm sorry i'm still trying to figure out
how to interact with zoom
and not have my computer crash at the
same time um
hopefully the font is large enough in
the notebook
cool so this is a snapshot i took from a
while ago
from venmo you can see if you look
really squint really hard you'll see
that leonard paid john
and hunter played brian and
erica paid monica and this is very very
easily represented
here as you know nodes and edges and
let's
let's actually do that in pure python or
in python with network x so let's
i'm alone um actually the code font is a
bit small
all right how about now
getting there really okay
okay it's gonna be a little challenging
but i'm sure we can make it work
okay that's fine okay okay this is like
super blind uh
okay cool so just import network
network x as nx because that's a
convention and then a bunch of other
stuff like pandas and metal played
and collections and so on uh so
in order to create your first network
with network x
here's what you need to do you need to
assign
g to be nx dot graph or call
the graph method from network x and you
created a network congratulations
um in network x anything really could be
served as nodes it doesn't have to be
for instance just an integer it could be
a bunch of stuff
and now now let's populate the graph
okay that we just created
and we will pass uh in order to
um to populate the graph we created with
this data here
we'll just pass it as a list of tuples
so
as we saw earlier leonardo paid john
hunter paid
brian and erica paid monica will asked
will uh use the add edges from
method bang done
um and if you don't you don't have to
believe me let's let's
just you know visualize it so there is a
very useful
draw network x method really i mean
basically you pass g which is the
network and then a bunch of other
parameters just to make it
look nicer but you know you don't need
to spend too much time
thinking about it and you can see this
is exactly what we saw
up there only this is from a network we
just created
use network x so bam within like two
minutes we created our first network
which is nice but it's not super
exciting because it's a stupid
small network with you know six actors
and three edges so let's do it in kind
of a larger scale
again as i mentioned if you look long
enough on the internet you will find
data sets for venmo and
what we'll do is use a larger data set
which is a very large graph
and then this is the plan we'll start
from the large data set
we'll break it down to smaller sub
graphs
we'll zoom into one of the subgraphs
and in that one we'll discover
communities
and we'll discuss what communities mean
in a little bit and then after we find
the communities we'll actually look at
interesting individuals
in those communities sounds good
thank you noah um cool so let's load
a bigger data set uh we'll do it with
pandas
and here we go so this is
there are six six hundred thousand
records and basically we have send their
id and receive the ids and that is the
person who sent money and the receiver
id is the id for the person
who received the money uh at this point
i should say that all the data you'll
see today has been
obfuscated so and anonymized so you know
there's nothing here that
uh that will be identifiable for the
people who were actually in the original
data set
but the structure of the network is
preserved because i just obfuscated
the actual ids and other data
um so at this point what you can do
is you can use a from pandas edge list
method to populate a network with
you know your data frame you just pass
the data frame you define what the
source is
who send to whom uh what the target is
what the target is who
received the money or you know in any
other case that you may have
and then you will create actually a
digraph
uh which is a directed graph what i
mentioned earlier which makes sense in
the venmo case because the fact that i
sent no money
does not necessarily unfortunately mean
that she sends it back to me
and i'm sorry no if i'm using you too
much as an example because you are
the only thing from the zoom from zoom i
can see right now so unfortunately for
you
uh i'll have to go back to you quite a
bit
um yeah let's run that it will take a
little bit of time
fingers crossed fingers crossed
there you go okay so
we have uh we mentioned that we have 637
thousand records uh so those are the
transfers
but those transfers occur between
about 710 000 different individuals
okay and we see that there are actually
also zero isolates
so these are nodes that don't receive
anything or don't send anything
which makes sense that we don't have
them in our data set because other why
would they'll be there
if we have a transactional dataset cool
so if we wanted to visualize that cloud
network and remember what i told you
about
networkx having shortcomings in the
visualization of large networks
department this is what we'll get
the red dots are the nodes and the
black lines are the edges so
i don't know what about you but for me
this is not
very useful um so
what what what can we do so we can use
other you know we can
visualize it with other tools and figure
out a way to do it or we can
for the sake of this presentation we can
kind of zoom in
on one subgroup within that network
and kind of visualize that if it will be
like
smaller and more user-friendly um
and yeah let's let's go with that
because um
i'm more concerned with like an
intuitive understanding of
like a small scale network rather than
trying to really make sense of a huge
huge graph
cool so let's find those uh sub
sub subgroups or sub graphs inside this
big giant graph that we created those
things are known as
connected components and connected
components are
basically subsets of the original nodes
that follow two rules first of all there
is a path
which is the wall that we learned
earlier between any two nodes
in the subset and there is no path to
any other node elsewhere so
in the very basic facebook example we
saw earlier
this is actually this is the entire
graph and it's also a connected
component because if you wanted to
reach one node from another node
there is a path you can find a path so
this is one big connected component
however if i came with
a big pair of scissors and i sever the
connection here
between blondie and blondie then
i would get two connected components
okay
because here is one connected component
because i can get
here i can get uh from you know one node
to another there is a path and here
i can get from any one node to another
there is a path
but there is nothing in between i can't
get
there is no path to another node so
these are self-contained
and diesels and self-contained and in
networks terminology this is called a
connected component
um as you can imagine
there is a built-in method to do that in
network x
um i don't need to run that because it's
a stupid example
we will use uh something that's called a
weekly connected component i'm not going
to get into the intricacies right now
i don't want to confuse people too much
but
trust me for the sake of argument
so weekly connected component we are
going to run that
for a bit it's a little intensive
and we'll see
that we generate some stats and we see
from
you know that large network of 700
southern
uh interactions we created we found a
bunch of connected components and the
biggest connecting component
inside that network has eighteen
thousand
six hundred and thirty members which is
pretty cool because think of if you
think about it you know
it's likely that many people of those
eighteen thousand
six hundred and thirty don't know each
other but there is a path so if they
really wanted to transfer money
to you know if they found a person
random person on the street
uh was you know in that 18
630 they could find a pass which is
fairly cool and it's also fairly cool
that we could find this huge community
lurking inside the bigger the bigger
graph
and if you kind of plot the top five
we'll see that you know the second
biggest one is
1800 strong and so on it goes down
pretty rapidly
now uh as a presenter of zoom
talk i have the benefit of cherry
picking the
data points i wanted to handle so i'll
do just that
these are this is one connected
component that i
cherry picked from the data and i'll use
that these are all user ids and i'll use
that to create a sub graph
a subgraph uh is basically a subset of
the original nodes
and networkx knows how to handle that so
if you take if we'll define uh g
sub which is g subgraph and we just
take the original graph g the big one of
700 thousand
and we use the subgraph method and we
specify which nodes
network x knows to take those nodes and
all of the connection of the graph
structure between them
and which is very useful so we see that
there are 14 hours there are 78
connections between them which is
much more manageable and actually i'm
going to try to
visualize that again with the same draw
method
but given that i zoomed in like 200 i'm
not sure
what we're gonna actually see okay it's
manageable it's manageable
it's not too bad now this
is even though it doesn't fit the entire
screen i think maybe if i'll do
this it will here we go you can see that
it's
much much more user friendly and much
more interesting
than the other thing that we saw earlier
okay so
cool i'm gonna jump back and forth
um let's add user ids just so
you know we can you can see that it's
easy to do so
we just have need to add with labels um
keyword eventually it will come up
i didn't appreciate how much uh zoom
slows down your computer
okay so we added because it is great
it's not very uh you know useful so
let's add the
the names uh i'm gonna read another data
data
uh data frame that has you know plots
that connects uh user ids to first name
and gender for example
doesn't really matter the point i'm
trying to make here is that
you can also in addition to the nodes
and edges you can also apply
uh attributes to
to to to your graph and
[Music]
that's useful like if you want to do
something a little bit more complicated
so i added the names you're probably not
going to see them very clearly that's
fine you'll see
you will make it better in a sec um
let's let's just take a quick break and
kind of
see where we are so we started from a
large network
which wasn't manageable in inside our
notebook
for today then we decided to zoom in on
one sub graph
subgraph which is all these nice people
now what we're going to do next is when
we're going to detect communities and
we're going to zoom in
on individuals so what do i mean by
communities
um this and hopefully you'll see it
clearly now
this structure is interesting and
intuitively if we kind of had to eyeball
it we would say that we can detect
communities ourselves
all of these people over here seem like
a community of their own
and these people look like a tight-knit
community and these people
and these people these people are all
kind of separate communities
so if we had to eyeball it you know that
kind of makes sense
but how do we do it with python um let's
head back um it's a little complicated
uh again as i mentioned some of the
algorithms
to actually do something in python are
quite uh
quite sophisticated i i'll say that
intuitively the way
to think about communities is that
you know you have your own group of
friends
some other person you know has their own
group of friends
and you don't know that person's friends
and your friends don't know that
person's friends
but i am aware that there is another
person that i kind of know that has
their own
his own friends so unlike uh connected
components which
you know were completely separate
entities
when you look at communities and there
are basically tight-knit groups
that are weakly connected to one another
that there is some knowledge of one
another but they don't really hang out
um i hope that makes sense
um the way we'll actually do it the way
we'll actually detect communities in our
subgraph is by cheating
um we want to use something built in
network x we'll use
a library called python after
leuven after the algorithm
and yeah we ran it
we fun found them it's fairly very
straightforward and then
what i'm doing here is i'm actually
going to plot
the same network we saw earlier but i
used the data that we found in the
communities
and then every community that that algo
just detected
will get a different color so let's
let's see what i mean
there you go i hope you can see it again
it's kind of
a little bit of a problem problem here
when i had to zoom in
but if you really squint very very hard
you'll see
that all of these people that we saw
earlier that we said hey this kind of
look like
community well they are they're yellow
they got
they got their own color they're yellow
and all of these people
yeah there's a question on youtube which
might be interesting
right now that person would like to know
if
we can determine the width of the edges
by some metric
i'm not exactly sure what this person
means but
does it make sense to you it does make
sense to me i'll come back to it in the
end
uh it's a it's a great question um
and i kind of uh kind of mentioned it
before in the deck i said there's also
like multi graphs and stuff
uh so multi graphs basically kind of
refer to you know when the a
relationship between nodes could have
multiple edges so
for instance i can send noah money on
venmo several times
and then you can you can kind of look at
the number of times i send more money or
the amounts
and kind of determine that
our relationship may be stronger and
kind of kind of give
a weight to the edge which will be
proportional to the
you know either the number of times i
send her money or
uh or the total sum and stuff like that
but i'm
really trying to keep things uh simple
it's it's it's a great question it's the
next step
definitely um but i'm really
doing the bare bones here uh to
try to keep the conversation going and i
do have a a
a hard stop soon so i'm just trying to
power slew
the information um that's all right okay
thanks
cool so just to recap as we said earlier
we're kind of seeing that
the algo managed to detect what we
what what we saw by eyeballing the data
that this is a community by itself and
these people our community and these
people our community
what we managed to kind of see
intuitively so did the algorithm
and now is the question here's a
question for you who are
like the important nodes in the this
network
um and again eyeballing it you can kind
of say
there's a few interesting individuals
here that kind of get a lot of uh
you know they're in the center and then
they get a lot of arrows that come in
and out they have a lot of edges
let's do it um in kind of
network analysis speak so there are a
lot of ways to scroll or
rank nodes um there and there is no one
right way depends on like the context
and the goal
um there is uh one of the
basic uh and most naive ones is called
like degree centrality and
you can also think about is like in and
out degree centrality which
uh goes back to what uh that person from
youtube just asked so basically
you know if i have a lot of notes of a
lot of people sending me money
then maybe i'm more important than
someone who just have you know one
transaction on demo
that's a very naive way to look at it
and there are
a few things that are a little bit more
complex like between centrality
which we'll see in a bait or pagerank
page rank is the algorithm that
was developed by larry page and sergey
brin
and you know how they ranked each each
website on the internet and kind of
managed to kind of plot them on the
network and figure out who's
which website is more interesting than
another and then they built a small
company called google and addresses
history
between centrality um which is one of
the the metrics we
will use just now is uh very interesting
so just kind of to give you an intuitive
sense of it
if we talked about pass earlier
we can think that you know it whenever
we want to guess from one node to
another we would like to find the
shortest path
because why go long if you can go short
and what between betweenness centrality
basically means
uh in kind of intuitive way is that
notes
that are more
uh prominent in that
belong to more shortest paths between
any two nodes
these are more important nodes which
kind of intuitively make sense these are
the connectors or the influencers or the
kind of the strongest you know people in
the in the network
because everything goes through them um
and you know network x obviously has
centrality measures so
you need to call network x centrality
between centrality
you'll get scores for each node and then
if we kind of go back and just
you know plug dodge code this course
that we just calculated
into network x then we can visualize it
again it will take a second to run
and you can see that you know data on
linkedin
lincoln over here you'll use third
are more interesting uh or more
important notes
depending on the between essentiality so
the larger the node the more
uh important that person is and in the
interest of time i'm just going to
kind of pre-screw this and we're going
to do the same with
the pagerank algorithm and we can see
that people kind of in
kind of in the center of the network
are relatively more important than
people on the side
so just to tie it back to our
original questions that we asked if i'm
the customer service team
whose customer service call should we
answer first and the answer is one of
those important notes in the middle
because if i look at just this guy this
guy alberto
if i give him obviously as a company i
would like to give everyone
a good service but you know there are
constraints
so if i have two calls one is one of
them is from
you know lincoln one one is from alberto
i would like to answer
lincoln's call first and i would if i
had only 10 pounds to give in
compensation i would like to give
you know lincoln all that 10 pounds
probably because if alberto doesn't
use the app anymore that's fine
because he only you know he only is
connected to one person on the network
so
the collateral damage of losing alberto
is just losing one person
but if i'm losing if i give lincoln
a bad customer experience and i'm losing
him
then all of these connections will be
severed so i'm at risk of losing more
individuals and similarly you know the
marketing team wanted to know who the
influences are so we can see kind of
from different centrality measures who
are the influencers and likewise
customer research team wants to know who
to interview and
product team wants to know uh you know
who are the better testers so what
should we keep in mind when we're
launching
or we're kind of thinking about new
features then
those power users are often the kind of
people you want to interview because
they would have interesting insights in
what
uh make the product kind of uh be
adopted by more and more people so these
are the people you need to keep in mind
now um and i'm sorry i'm rushing through
things i do have a hard stop
uh so i just want to wrap up nicely
um and i'm gonna skip through these
there is a eurovision exam voting
examiner you can see the link right here
i'll publish it basically it looks at
um all of the eurovision votes along the
years
and sees you know which companies give
which countries will give
votes to which other countries and you
can see blocks you can definitely use
blocks and i think that you kind of can
kind of guess which
what the blocks look like yourselves
because if you have ever seen
a eurovision song contest you know that
you know it's a really good game
let's be honest in my opinion
um cool so closing remarks okay
we we we answered a real world business
question using network analysis in just
a few minutes okay
which is pretty cool um we saw that it's
it's powerful it's widely applicable um
we barely scratched the surface so there
is a whole lot to learn
um and i encourage every one of you to
to go
and i will publish in coming days i will
publish
a lot of reading material uh and and
other sources you can read
uh to go and study it even more even
read the documentation on network x
because that's even
another good way to kind of familiarize
yourself with more and more things that
have to do with network analysis um and
yeah and python is great
so i'll i'll post a lot of uh um
next steps and and you know links that
you should go to
also kind of try to show the slides and
code in some manner
um i'm not sure exactly how just yet
but i'm i'll kind of reach out to noah
when i have the exact detail
so you can follow me on on twitter and
i'll probably also post it there at some
point
um so with that
uh i really thank you for the
opportunity i think it's really really
cool that we managed to talk
uh when there are people in indonesia
and buenos aires which is like
could not have anticipated that so thank
you
um and with that i'm gonna have to rush
to an a
to another call so thank you very much
everyone
um yes thank you alan very much
um we are gonna try now to have a break
which is some five to seven minutes
where we should interact with each other
um for this i'm gonna do first top two
things i will pause the recording
and i will stop the live stream so if
you are joining us
on youtube um please
we will be back in six minutes so at 755
billion times
which is um six minutes from now we will